[Musique]
bonjour je voudrais d'emblée faire appel
à votre imagination
alors nous allons tous nous projeter
dans 15 ans et imaginer que nous sommes
à l'hôpital là où je reçois les patients
en consultation de conseil génétique
nous sommes donc en 2035 et je vous
demande de fermer les yeux juste deux
petites secondes
nous y voilà
et bien voilà justement le prochain
couple qui arrive en consultation
bonjour madame bonjour messieurs comment
allez vous au moins ça va très bien voir
ça va quoi je vous en prie
installez-vous alors je reprends votre
dossier
ah oui je me souviens bien de vous un
c'est vous le couple qui aviez fait des
tests génétiques avant de concevoir un
enfant et c'est est montré que vous
étiez compatible à 92%
je m'en souviens parce que c'est un
score qu'on ne voit quand même pas très
souvent
et donc voilà vous avez opté pour la
fécondation in vitro 1 pour pouvoir
choisir votre embryons et vous venez
bien sûr pour avoir les résultats du
séquençage du génome de vaud embryons
alors je vois en fait que c'est pas mal
hein il ya quatre embryons qui sont de
qualité suffisante que pourrait être
réimplantés dans votre utérus madame
alors quelles sont leurs
caractéristiques alors le premier
embryon
mais c'est une petite fille hein mais
elle a quand même 70% de risques de
développer alzheimer après l'âge de 60
ans alors le deuxième embryons un petit
garçon quand même 30 % de risques de
développer des troubles du spectre de
l'autisme troisième embryon de petites
filles oh bah c'est pas mal on ne va pas
détecté de maladie génétique grave
vous devez juste à voir que sa taille ne
dépassera pas 1 mètre 50 à l'âge adulte
aïe le quatrième en brillance et un
petit garçon à nouveau et il aura 80 %
de risques de développer un cancer du
côlon avant l'âge
60 ans mais oui je me rends bien compte
1 c'est pas facile de devoir faire un
choix
mais en même temps vous allez déjà à
votre troisième cycle et rappelez vous
c'est le dernier cycle qui est financé
par la sécurité sociale et les deux
premières fois finalement vous vous
étiez pas décidé donc c'est un peu votre
dernière chose se choisir un embryon
alors est ce que c'est de la science
fiction ou est ce que c'est la réalité
je vous rassure on en est pas encore là
mais je voudrais qu'aujourd'hui on
réfléchisse ensemble sur la direction
pourrait prendre la génétique médicale à
l'avenir en regard des nouvelles
technologies alors bien sûr la génétique
c'est une chance extraordinaire sinon je
n'aurais pas fait mon métier et vous
avez déjà tous entendu parler des
chromosomes et des gènes mais pour être
sûr que tout le monde est à niveau je
vous rappelle que notre corps est
constitué de milliards de cellules et
dans chaque cellule il y a un noyau qui
est un espèce de petit coffre-fort qui
est là pour protéger notre matériel
génétique et le matériel génétique c'est
ce que nous appelons notre génome alors
dans le noyau le matériel génétique le
génome prend la forme de chromosomes des
petits bâtonnets et vous savez que chez
l'être humain
il y à 23 paires de chromosomes dont 46
chromosomes et un chromosome en fait
c'est de la dnc qui est vraiment compact
et sur lui-même c'est comme une pelote
d'adr et si dans le noyau d'une cellule
je déroule tous les chromosomes et bien
je vais obtenir à peu près 2 mètres da
dn1 qui est cette fameuse double hélice
dont vous avez tous entendu parler et
qui est constituée de quatre éléments
essentiels qu'on appelle les nucléotides
et qui sont symbolisés par les lettres à
thé cpg et ces quatre lettres elles se
succèdent dans un certain ordre le long
de notre génome pour former des milliers
de codes et ses codes ce sont les gènes
et donc les jeunes se sont toutes les
recettes de cuisine qui nous font qu'ils
nous fabrique et qui nous font
fonctionner
alors quand on reprend l'histoire de la
génétique nique et bien il faut
retourner aux années 60 on a commencé à
regarder de plus en plus régulièrement
les chromosomes humains au microscope et
c'est à cette époque qu'on s'est rendu
compte que les enfants atteints de
trisomie 21 est bien le posséder trois
chromosomes 21 ans au lieu de deux et
puis dans les années 80 on a identifié
les premiers gène responsable des
maladies génétiques les plus fréquentes
et on s'est surtout rendu compte que des
maladies génétiques était due au fait qu
une faute de frappe se mettait dans un
gène important et empêcher ce gène de
fonctionner et à cette époque
finalement la démarche du généticien
cliniciens été un peu toujours la même
il voyait un patient consultation et sur
base des symptômes du patient et de son
histoire familiale
il émettait une hypothèse diagnostic et
finalement ils prescrivent à un test
génétique ciblé simplement pour
confirmer ou infirmer cette hypothèse
diagnostic et bien en fait nous allons
voir aujourd'hui qu'avec l'avènement de
plusieurs nouvelles technologies notre
façon d'exercer notre métier de
généticiens cliniciens c'est un petit
peu modifié alors depuis le début du
xxième siècle depuis le début des années
2000 il faut savoir qu'en génétique il
ya eu deux très grandes révolutions
technologiques
la première c'est ce qu'on appelle les
micros arrêts et c'est une analyse qui
permet d'examiner les chromosomes de
manière bien plus détaillée qu'au
microscope est la deuxième grande
révolution technologique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le séquençage à
haut débit qui permet de lire les gêne
beaucoup plus facilement qu'auparavant
alors nous allons commencer par les
micros arrêts c'est un petit peu comme
si on arrivait à découper les
chromosomes en milliers de petits
morceaux pour vous donner un exemple
plus imagé 1 et bien dans les années 60
ou 70 quand on regardait des chromosomes
au microscope c'est un peu comme si le
scientifique
regardez un puzzle de 46 pièce 46
chromosomes pour voir s'il ne trouvait
pas une pièce manquante ou une pièce en
trop et bien maintenant le scientifique
il regarde un chromosome de 280 mille
pièces pour voir s'il ya pas une toute
petite pièce en moins ou une toute
petite pièce en trop et c'est toute
petite pièce manquante ou en trop dans
notre
dans notre matériel génétique dans nos
chromosomes c'est ce que nous appelons
dans notre langage de généticiens des
remaniements chromosomique et en fait on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait 3 sort
de remaniement chromosomiques
il ya des variantes remaniement
chromosome y qui sont tout à fait bénin
qui n'ont aucune répercussion sur notre
santé et puis l inverse il ya des
remaniements chromosome y qui sont
graves qui entraîne des symptômes
on dit que ce sont des remaniements
chromosomiques pathogènes qui donne des
syndromes chromosomiques
mais on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
une troisième catégorie de remaniement
qui sont les facteurs de risque
alors en fait les facteurs de risque on
peut les retrouver chez n'importe qui
dans la population générale et on peut
tout à fait la retrouver j'ai des
personnes qui ne se plaignent absolument
de rien mais statistiquement on va les
retrouver avec une fréquence un peu plus
importante chez les personnes qui ont ce
qu'on appelle des troubles du nouveau
développement
ça veut dire par exemple des personnes
qui ont une déficience intellectuelle ou
des personnes qui ont des troubles du
spectre autistique ou des personnes qui
ont de l'épilepsie ou encore des
personnes qui ont des maladies
psychiatriques
alors la découverte de ces facteurs de
risque pour les troubles
neurodéveloppementaux eh bien il faut
savoir qu'elle a fort modifier notre
façon de donner un conseil génétique et
pour que vous compreniez je vais vous
donner un exemple très simple vous avez
un couple et madame est enceinte et au
mieux la grossesse elle mangeait son
gynécologue pour faire l'échographie que
toutes les femmes enceintes font au
milieu de la grossesse puis
malheureusement bel gynécologue on voit
qu'il est inquiet le bébé ne grandit pas
bien ils suspectent une malformation au
niveau cardiaque et donc vu son
inquiétude le gynécologue va proposer à
la patiente de réaliser une amniocentèse
donc on va ponctionner le liquide qui
entoure le bébé dans le but de vérifier
que ce bébé n'est pas atteint d'une
trisomie 21 ou d'un autre syndrome
chromosomiques grave alors nous au
laboratoire nous recevons le liquide
amniotique on l'analyse avec la fameuse
technique des micros arrêts et on est
bien content de constater que ce bébé en
fait à deux
romo zone 21 dont il n'est pas atteint
de trisomie 21 et on ne voit pas non
plus d'autres syndromes chromosomiques
grave mais par contre un peu par hasard
jeudi par hasard parce que ça n'a sans
doute rien à voir avec les petits signes
que le gynéco grain que le gynécologue
avait vu à l'échographie mais un peu par
hasard on remarque ce bébé il y manque
une toute petite bande sur le chromosome
1 et nous généticien on sait que cette
petite pièce manquante sur le chromosome
en fait c'est un facteur de risque pour
les troubles neurodéveloppementaux et
nous savons qu'avec cette petite bande
en moins ce bébé à 60% de chances
d'aller très bien et de n'en avoir aucun
symptôme mais il a quand même 40 % de
risques de développer des troubles du
nouveau développement par exemple de la
déficience intellectuelle ou par exemple
des troubles autistiques
alors que devons-nous faire avec ce
résultat est ce que nous devons garder
pour nous et où est ce que nous devons
le transmettre au couple alors ya une
règle un consensus national qui a été
édictée par un consortium
multidisciplinaire qui nous dit que si
le risque de trouble du nouveau
développement est supérieure à 30%
nous avons le devoir en tant que
médecins d'informer les patients donc
nous devons revoir ce couple en
consultation et leur dire que d'une part
on a une bonne nouvelle le bébé n'est
pas atteint de trisomie 21 ou d'un autre
syndrome chromosomiques sévère mais que
d'un autre côté on a une moins bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il est porteur d'un
facteur de risque pour les troubles du
nouveau développement
alors vous imaginez un peu le tsunami
qu'on provoque chez ce couple qui ne
s'attendait pas du tout à ce genre de
résultat le couple y vient en se disant
ça va être noir ou blanc à l'enfant est
atteint on l'enfant va bien mais jamais
il n'aurait imaginé devoir prendre une
décision pour la grossesse en cours
non pas sur un diagnostic mais
simplement sur un risque alors là je
voulais illustrer comment les micros
arrêt nous permettent d'analyser les
chromosomes de manière de plus en plus
détaillée et comment ça influence eu
notre conseil génétique mais il faut
savoir qu'il ya une deuxième très grande
révolution technologique depuis quelques
années
qui est le fameux séquençage à haut
débit alors ça c'est assez génial parce
que ce séquençage à haut débit il nous
permet de lire les gêne beaucoup plus
facilement qu'auparavant
auparavant on ne pouvait lire qu'un seul
gène à la fois c'était assez fastidieux
la preuve c'est que quand les américains
ont voulu séquencé pour la première fois
l'entièreté du génome d'un seul être
humain
ça leur a pris 14 ans et des milliards
de dollars et maintenant pour un peu
moins de 1500 euros en quelques jours on
peut lire tous les jeunes d'un patient
dans nos laboratoires de génétique
alors ça c'est fantastique pour nous
généticien parce que ça a révolutionné
notre métier parce que ça nous permet de
prescrire des analyses génétiques
beaucoup beaucoup plus large chez les
patients on étudie des centaines ou des
milliers de gènes et ça nous permet
chaque jour de poser de nouveaux
diagnostics parfois de maladie génétique
très très très rare qu'on n'aurait pas
pu diagnostiquer avec les anciennes
technologies mais hermé il ne faut pas
croire pour autant que cette nouvelle
technique de séquençage à haut débit
c'est comme une baguette magique qui
nous permet de trouver la solution pour
tous les patients parce que notre génome
ça reste quelque chose de très complexe
et il faut savoir qu'il ya un pour cent
de notre site génomes qui est soumis à
des variations
ça veut dire que si je compare mes gènes
avec vos gènes madame
eh bien il faut pas croire que nous
allons avoir exactement le même code
génétique il va y avoir des milliers de
différence entre vous et moi et ses
milliers de différence c'est ce qui fait
que nous sommes tous différents les uns
des autres et donc quand nous voyons un
patient en consultation et que nous nous
disons que ces symptômes peut être
pourrais évoquer être dues par être
causée par une maladie génétique rare
ben il faut pas croire qu'ils nous
suffit de prendre l'adn du patient de le
mettre dans la fameuse machine de
séquençage à haut débit et qu'elle
quelques jours après on va recevoir un
petit carton qui dit votre passion est
atteint de telles pathologies banon
c'est beaucoup trop simple en fait la
machine elle nous sort une espèce de
manuscrits qui contient des millions de
lettres et qui correspond au code
génétique de notre passion et quand nous
comparons le code génétique de notre
patient à un génome de référence et bien
inévitablement nous observons des
milliers de différentes des milliers de
petits variant et donc notre métier de
généticiens aujourd'hui c'est d'aller
chercher dans ces milliers de petits
variant lequel finalement pourraient
être responsables des symptômes de mon
patient alors parfois on a de la chance
parfois on voit vraiment invariants qui
se trouve dans le code génétique d'un
gène très important et qui empêche ce
jana de fonctionner et donc ça nous
permet vraiment de poser un diagnostic
d'une pathologie génétique parfois très
rares mais il arrive encore très souvent
qu'on se retrouve avec plein de points
d'interrogation parce qu'en fait on est
encore incapable de comprendre la
signification de tous les variants de
notre génome
donc c'est un petit peu on peut imaginer
un simple comme un botaniste qui
arriverait dans une forêt où il ya des
milliers d'espèces de nouvelles espèces
de champignons belle botaniste sera pas
dire dès le départ qu'elle chante pignon
sont comestibles et quelques champignons
sont venus mais nous généticien c'est un
peu pareil on avance pas à pas nos
connaissances évoluent mais on est
encore incapable de déterminer la
signification de tous les variants et
donc il ya toute une série de variantes
on ne sait pas si on doit la les
catégoriser dans les variants bénin ou
dans les variants pathogènes ou dans les
facteurs de risque et donc si ces
nouvelles technologies
c'est pas une baguette magique qui
permet de trouver la solution pour tous
les patients baisser encore moins une
espèce de boule de cristal qui
transformerait les généticiens hand et
madame irma et donc je suis vraiment
furieux quand je vois certaines dérives
commerciales comme présent il ya une
firme aux états unis qui prétendent
déterminée pour commun 1400 $ déterminer
l'avenir d'un enfant simplement en
analysant les gènes à partir d'un
frottis de salive d'un bébé à la
naissance et donc soit disant ils
prédisent aux parents si le bébé sera
sportif ou artistique sera plutôt
manuelle ou intellectuelle
si ce sera un meneur ou bien s'il y sera
très timide et même s'il aura des
tendances à l'alcoolisme ou à la
consommation de drogue
c'est vraiment bien entendu une vraie
supercherie alors bien loin de moi quand
même l'idée de remettre en question tous
les progrès tous les bénéfices que l'on
obtient par ces nouvelles technologies
ça a vraiment changé nos métiers de
généticiens ça nous a permis d'avancer
dans nos connaissances et de finalement
apporté de plus en plus de réponses à
des patients qui sont parfois enquête
diagnostic depuis de très nombreuses
années
et puis j'espère surtout à l'avenir que
pour tous ces patients ça va ouvrir des
perspectives thérapeutiques je crois
vraiment très fort en la recherche sur
la thérapie génique ou sur l'utilisation
des cellules souches mais ce qui
sous-tend ma réflexion aujourd'hui c'est
que finalement nous vivons dans une
société qui n'accepte plus l'inconnu
nous voulons vraiment maîtriser au
maximum tous les risques et nous vivons
aussi dans une société où on cultive le
mythe de l'enfant parfait alors
j'observe qu'il y a une tendance à
vouloir proposer de plus en plus de
tests à des couples en
préconceptionnelle ça veut dire avant de
concevoir un enfant
et j'en pense en particulier à la mise
au point d'un test qui constituerait à
séquencer des centaines de gènes dans un
couple pour vérifier que les futurs
parents ne sont pas porteurs de
pathologies génétiques ils pourraient
transmettre à leur descendance
alors bien sûr l'objectif louable c'est
un objectif de prévention et je peux
tout à fait comprendre que des couples
qui en ont les moyens et envies de
recourir à ce genre de test pour
diminuer le risque pathologies
génétiques dans leur descendance mais ce
qui m'inquiète ce qui me tracasse
vraiment c'est que je ne suis pas sûr
que ce genre de test sera toujours
accompagné d'une information
scientifique détaillée et nuancée et je
crains vraiment que des parents
l'interprète un résultat rassurant comme
l'équivalent d'une espèce de carte
blanche qui leur garantit l'enfant
parfait ou en tout cas l'enfant sont
maladie génétique parce que ça c'est
vraiment un leurre parce que même si ce
genre de test
meaney un peu le risque de pathologie
génétique dans la descendance un couple
on arrivera vraiment jamais au risque
zéro pour différentes raisons d'une part
parce que comme je voulais dit on him as
milieux de pouvoir interpréter la
signification de tous les variants de
notre génome et dont il ya toute une
série de variantes qu'on va voir chez
les parents et on sera incapable de dire
si ce sont des variantes tout à fait
bénin ou si en fait ce sont des
prédispositions à certaines pathologies
génétiques mais surtout ce qu'il ne faut
pas oublier c'est que la majorité des
pathologies génétiques sévère elles ne
sont pas hérité des parents elles
arrivent par accident chez un enfant
parce qu'au moment de la conception une
faute de frappe va se mettre par
accident dans le code d'un gène
important et va entraîner une pathologie
génétique et donc vous aurez beau faire
tous les tests génétiques préventives
possibles et imaginables chez les
parents en prie conceptionnelle vous ne
les mettrai jamais à l'abri d'avoir un
enfant qui a une pathologie génétique
par accident alors nous sommes dans une
société qui investit de plus en plus
dans la prévention et c'est très bien
mais je ne voudrais pas que le message
qui ce qui est sous jacent à ces
campagnes de prévention finalement
stigmatise encore plus les personnes en
situation de handicap et j'espère
vraiment que notre société est prête à
mettre au moins autant de moyens et
d'énergie pour la prise en charge des
patients en situation de handicap et
pour la construction d'une société
handicap inclus alors je terminerai par
une réflexion beaucoup plus large de
tous temps de très grandes personnalités
ont fait évoluer notre société
je pense à des grands scientifiques
comme einstein ou des grands artistes
comme van gogh ou mozart ou encore des
grands philosophes comme nick
en fait je serais bien curieux pouvoir
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil sur
leur génome parce qu'à mon avis nous
réservera bien des surprises
alors revenons à notre fiction du départ
vous vous souvenez un ce couple qui
devait faire un choix parmi quatre
embryons
sur base des résultats de l'analyse de
leur génome et bien imaginons qu'un van
gogh ou qu'un mozart ou qu'un einstein
se cache parmi ces quatre embryons
pensez vous que cet embryon
constituerait nécessairement le premier
choix des parents alors je termine par
une phrase tout court qui m'a été cité
par un de mes patients et qui dit ceci
la différence c'est cette richesse que
nous avons tous en commun
je vous remercie pour votre attention
[Musique]